[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
details from inside the courtroom as
vanessa bryant takes the stand in her
lawsuit against officials over the
sharing of photos of her husband kobe
and their daughter gianna plus it's very
difficult these days to have a felony on
your record the attorney of a woman
acquitted of killing her newborn baby
sits down with law and crime after
skylar richardson seeks to have her
conviction sealed and do everything that
you can looking for fingerprints dna
sample anything else that might be there
there are going to be forensic tie backs
almost a year after the fatal shooting
on the set of alec baluin's movie rust
the film's armor is slamming law
enforcement over the investigation but
first jurors hear explicit testimony
from the former god daughter of r b
singer r kelly as he faces federal child
pornography charges in chicago long
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host terry austin attorneys for
r b singer r kelly get the chance to
question his former god daughter who was
allegedly seen in several of his child
pornography tapes when she was just 14
as she testifies against him in his
federal trial in chicago
the woman referred to as jane is now 37
years old she is testifying for the
first time that she is the girl in his
video after denying it for years jane
testified thursday that kelly told her
she shouldn't share their relationship
with anyone to demonstrate her loyalty
to him she said he asked her to recruit
her friends who were also minors to
participate in their sexual activities
she also testified that kelly had her
with hundreds of times before she turned
18. he raped her jane was at the center
of kelly's 2008 illinois trial over
child pornography charges the singer was
acquitted when jane and her family
denied it was her in the video while
kelly denies any wrongdoing he's charged
with child pornography enticement of
minors and conspiring to rig the 2008
trial by intimidating jane not to
testify kelly was already convicted last
year of sex trafficking and racketeering
in new york and was sentenced to 30
years in federal prison
joining us today our defense attorney
and guest co-host bernard villalona
along with a long crime legal analyst
matt mangini welcome and bernard i'm
going to start with you
this witness jane doe refused to testify
in the 2008 trial against r kelly do you
think that will be used against her in
this trial could the jurors not
understand why she did that
so as you can see the king of rmb is
continuing his tour and that is the tour
of courthouses answering up for the
charges that he has involving having sex
with minors so in regards to jane now
we've known about jane since the early
2000s because jane is the same young
girl that was pictured in a video where
r kelly is allegedly urinating on top of
her and she wasn't cooperative with the
state trial that's going to be mentioned
throughout the trial especially during
her cross-examination because what the
defense is trying to say is that she is
not credible that she has something to
gain by this testimony however remember
that one of the 13 charges that r kelly
is facing is that of conspiracy
conspiring to intimidate a witness or a
victim and jane is one of them because
she was paid off and sent to the bahamas
with her family in order to avoid being
present at the 2008 state trial that
resulted in an acquittal because she did
not testify right let's hope that there
is a different result here now long
crime analyst matt mandino the defense
has strenuously argued to keep any
videotapes out of this trial the
expectation that portions of the tapes
will be shown how damaging is that going
to be to the defense
well it's going to be very damaging i
mean this they're going to observe
pornographic videos they're going to see
this victim 14 years old
assaulted by r kelly i mean these tapes
are going to be the centerpiece of this
trial
and they're going to be very harmful to
r kelly that's right and maybe some of
the jurors have already seen those tapes
online we just don't know hopefully not
switching now to texas where the lawyer
for caitlyn armstrong a woman charged
with the murder of an elite cyclist says
police improperly interrogated his
client and ignored her request to speak
with the lawyer
armstrong is charged in the may 11
shooting death of anna mariah wilson
also known as mo wilson was found shot
to death in a friend's home while she
was in texas for a bike ride wilson had
previously been romantically involved
with armstrong's boyfriend colin
strickland investigators say days after
wilson's murder armstrong fled the
country she was arrested weeks later in
costa rica before all this happened a
warrant was issued for armstrong over a
2018 incident after the yoga teacher
failed to pay a spa's 650 bill for a
botox treatment on may 12 armstrong was
arrested and questioned about wilson's
death her attorney says armstrong wasn't
read her miranda rights and that
evidence was obtained illegally using
the theft warrant armstrong's next
hearing is set for next week
still ahead on long crime daily ohio
woman skyler richardson is seeking to
have her conviction sealed two years
since her acquittal of killing her
newborn baby after her prom
but first the armor from alec baldwin's
movie rust is questioning the
investigation into the on-set shooting
that killed cinematographer helena
hutchins
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the attorney for the armor
on the set of rust is calling out
sheriff's investigators after they
didn't request some forensic testing in
the case rust is the film where a
cinematographer was shot and killed by
alec baldwin last year law and crime's
angelette levy is here with the details
antonette
well terry you may recall that helena
hutchins died from a single gunshot
wound that gun was fired by alec baldwin
the actor director joel souza was
wounded in that incident in the film's
armor hannah gutierrez reid was in
charge of the firearms on the set now
gutierrez reid's lawyer is questioning
why the rounds in the gun that baldwin
fired were not tested for dna evidence
or fingerprints this came after fbi test
results were released earlier this week
which found that the gun could not have
fired without pulling the trigger
baldwin told abc news that he didn't
pull the trigger and that the first
assistant director dave halls handed him
the gun that day and said that it was
safe
i asked forensic death investigator
joseph scott morgan what he thought of
the rounds not being tested for either
dna or fingerprints
from an investigative standpoint i think
that it's important to go ahead and try
to cut
all of that static off
early on in the investigation do
everything that you can
looking for fingerprints dna sample
anything else that might be there there
are going to be forensic tie backs that
way you can say that it has been done
the problem is is that when you don't do
things that could have been done there
will always be questions
and i guess you have to ask the question
here
is it too late
now i reached out to the santa fe county
sheriff's office to see whether or not
they had a comment on jason bowles's
statement about this investigation i was
told that there would be no comment
terry
matt let me ask you this there's plenty
of blame to go around in this case
including the armorer the assistant
director who handed baldwin the gun and
baldwin himself at the end of the day
based on what you know so far do you
think anyone will be criminally charged
in this case
well terry i think it's going to be a
difficult prosecution for any of the
individuals involved in this case and
precisely for
the reasons that you said you know
number one uh you know why is there live
rounds why were there live rounds on the
set i mean that's the first question who
brought those live rounds to the set and
number two you know a gun is supposed to
be cleared and in this situation it
wasn't and and why wasn't that done and
then ultimately
we we hear from alec baldwin that he
didn't pull the trigger we hear it's
impossible someone had to pull the
trigger you know this is sort of like a
plane crash i mean a lot of things have
to go wrong uh for a plane to crash and
it appears in this situation
uh that there are a lot of problems and
now we learn about this lack of
forensic evidence when there was an
opportunity to collect that forensic
evidence that again is going to be uh
difficult uh for a prosecution uh of any
of these individuals so i don't see a
prosecution
like i don't think there's going to be
the ability to prove guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt of any individual
person i agree this was a tragic
situation now bernardo let me turn it to
you gutierrez reed she's the armor on
the set is asking for the dna to confirm
who actually placed the live rounds on
that set like matt mentioned we know
there was only one sufficient
supplier of those rounds and that was
seth kinney how important is that dna
testing going to be
it's of huge importance especially since
the number one question is who loaded
live rounds into that gun that's the
million dollar question in this case so
it's a huge misstep if law enforcement
did not did not request that it be
tested in terms of either swap for dna
or dusted for fingerprints it's either
one other other you can't do both
because it messes up the testing but
this is a huge misstep by law
enforcement if they didn't do it either
way in terms of yes we know there's one
guy who usually handles the supply of it
dna would tell you that yes one person
touched it it won't tell you when they
touch it just that that person's dna
sample did touch that uh shell casing or
the cartridge right and anjanette what's
the status of the investigation into
helena hutchinson's death hudson's death
well it's ongoing terry you know we've
asked several times when this could be
handed over to the prosecutor
for consideration and review
they could consider some potential
charges we still don't have an answer on
that we know that we got those fbi test
results back earlier
this week
about how you can't fire a gun without
pulling the trigger we kind of all knew
that
we do know that they say that hannah
gutierrez reid actually loaded the gun
that day and said so in her statement to
law enforcement so
those are the things we know as it
pertains to loading the gun and where
the investigation stands it's ongoing
yeah thanks everyone listen coming up on
long crime daily an ohio woman acquitted
in the death of her newborn baby files a
motion to have her conviction of the
lesser charge abuse of a corpse sealed
two years after her trial
plus the widow of kobe bryant testifies
in california as she sues los angeles
county following the fatal crash that
killed her husband and daughter
[Music]
welcome back the attorney of an ohio
woman acquitted of killing her newborn
baby hours after her senior prom sits
down with us a week after filing a
motion to get her criminal conviction of
a lesser charge sealed in 2017
richardson was just 18 years old when
she secretly gave birth to a baby girl
at her home then buried the remains she
initially faced aggravated murder
involuntary manslaughter and child
endangerment charges but she was
acquitted and convicted of abusing of a
corpse which is still a felony crime she
was sentenced to seven days in county
jail which she had already served and
three years of community control but 14
months later a judge terminated that
sentence richardson now wants the
conviction record sealed her attorney
charlie rickers says having a felony
conviction even a fifth degree one is
still keeping her from moving forward
with her life
it's very difficult these days to have a
felony on your record
and to be able to have gainful
employment uh a lot of opportunities are
lost in simple things even like where
you can live apartments that you can
rent
but obvious things like education higher
education opportunities which skyler
really wants to pursue
as well as job opportunities that she's
lost out on because she has this felony
on her record
the prosecutors in the case tell long
crime he hasn't reviewed richardson's
request but he plans to and will file a
response with the court
bernardo let me turn to you richardson's
attorney did an incredible job during
the trial knocking out those top charges
what are his chances of you know sealing
the actual abuse of court's conviction
absolutely terry and i watched that
trial from the beginning to the end and
the defense actually did an excellent
job and that's why i resulted with a
non-homicide conviction i think she has
a good probability of getting her record
sealed and the reasons why it's number
one it's not a violent crime number two
she would be able she was able to
actually follow the parameters of her
supervision to the point that they even
cut it short and number three let's see
if the prosecutor is going to oppose the
ceiling if the prosecutor doesn't oppose
the ceiling then it's very likely that
her record will be sealed all great
points thanks bernard and matt let me
turn to you this was a widely publicized
case and i'm actually thinking do you
think the ceiling of her conviction will
help because frankly i think people
already know all about what happened in
this case
well that you may be right terry and you
know she is convicted of a felony and
what
what her attorney is talking about are
the collateral consequences of crime
which everyone who's convicted of of a
felony uh has to deal with and those
issues are you know job applications uh
certain government benefits uh
other uh uh educational matters so so
you know this is a problem across the
country
of felonies and i think the fact that
that she has gone off probation early
might be an indication that that she
could get it sealed uh but it is a major
problem nationwide
absolutely and maybe they'll take the
fact that she was young at the time into
consideration when we come back vanessa
bryant takes the stand in los angeles as
the widow of the late kobe bryant
testifies in her federal lawsuit against
county officials
[Music]
welcome back vanessa bryant takes the
stand in her lawsuit against the county
of los angeles as she sues for emotional
distress over photos that were taken at
the scene of the fatal helicopter crash
that killed her husband and her daughter
the 2020 crash killed kobe bryant their
daughter gianna and seven others brian's
lawsuit claims close-up photos were
taking of the remains of the basketball
star and his daughter and that they were
distributed among first responders and
even shared with members of the public
on several occasions friday morning
vanessa bryant wept on the stand telling
jurors she expected law enforcement to
have more compassion and respect and
that her husband and daughter deserve
dignity she said anyone who photographed
her daughter's remains was quote taking
advantage of the fact that her daddy
couldn't protect her because he was at
the morgue long crimes megan kunith was
inside the courtroom for the emotional
testimony
it was a big day with vanessa bryant
taking the stand and that has really
been
the most anticipated testimony and she
she was emotional but she was also very
well composed there were definitely some
emotional moments and some heavy crying
as she you know described her
relationship with kobe over the years it
was very emotional and heavy to hear her
talk about these photos and then
then her her obviously very
knowledgeable and and smart analysis of
what she saw in trial and she was really
knowledgeable about the the facts of the
case and what the sheriff's department
did here
matt let me turn to you first the
testimony of vanessa bryant was very
emotional the jury is instructed to
follow the law though so how impactful
do you think this testimony is going to
be in front of that jury
well terry we know that judges
frequently admonish jurors you know not
to be
taken by the emotion to stick with the
fact that they're hearing from
uh the witnesses the people who take the
witness stand but in this case you know
you can't overlook this emotion it
appears that her emotion was genuine uh
we heard that she was well prepared and
wrote well versed for her testimony
and if you convey that genuine emotion
uh to a jury uh you know they're gonna
be sympathetic it's just human nature
you can't separate that emotion uh from
the facts of the trial
and while i think
they'll continue to admonish this jury
to stick with the facts they're not
going to forget this compelling
testimony absolutely it sounds like it
was extremely emotional in that
courtroom bernard vanessa bryant is
suing los angeles county technically for
negligence invasion of privacy and also
emotional distress from a legal
standpoint do you think she will be
successful
i think she's going to be successful the
question is going to be how much money
will she be entitled to in terms of
compensatory damages as well as punitive
damages i will be looking more at the
punitive damages because that is how a
jury sends a message and acknowledges
that what you did was wrong and we need
to prevent these types of actions from
taking place again in the future
especially you don't want investigators
releasing photographs you don't want
that to happen
thank you for joining us and thank you
all we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you